uh london hospitals are extremely busy
at the moment we're still seeing a high
number of covered patients we've got
over four thousand
kobe patients in london at the moment
and we know that sickness absence
continues to go up and and that in line
with the nurse levels of nurse vacancy
rates that we have and the increasing
pressures mean that currently it's a
very challenging situation to work in at
the moment
and what kind of levels of absenteeism
have you got currently well i mean it's
it's um it's different across the across
the capital depending on trust but we
are seeing still significant absences um
due to both covered sickness and also
having to to isolate which is impacting
on services across the capital not just
in in hospitals but in the community and
in primary care as well
and is this situation getting worse or
is it stabilized over recent days
well i think the fact that we've had to
bring the the army really demonstrates
the huge pressures that services are
under at the moment and my members will
tell you that it doesn't feel like it's
stabilizing at the moment
and at the moment like they can't see
an end to it you know we we do have um
nurses that aren't exhausted they really
are burnt out at the moment and they're
very very stretched
yeah what will the army be doing or the
armed forces certainly the military uh
be doing now that they have been
deployed these 200 or so
um at the moment the the the specific
details around what they're going to be
doing um have yet to be made clear we
know that they are being um deployed
across the capital we know that i think
it's around 20 are going to to bart's
hospital but their specific duties i
think are unclear at the moment we're
being told that 40 of them are medics
and will actually be able to help treat
patients and that the others will be in
a more supportive facet
can they do the job of
absent medical staff
i think we need to be very clear it
takes a long time to to train as a nurse
and and we can't just it's we can't just
replace that with people doing tasks
and we're already seeing that nurses are
stretched um already trying to to care
for patients although this is
a welcome short-term fix it doesn't
actually resolve any of the long-term
issues that we have within the health
service
so a cautious welcome then it sounds uh
the military from you that the military
are being brought in
we're gonna welcome any any help that
is offered but it's obviously only a
short-term fix and we have i mean let's
be clear in the capital we've got over
9000 nurse vacancies so uh 200 personnel
is
is is welcome support but it isn't
really going to fix those issues that
are there
could you have predicted such i presume
you're calling it a crisis could you
have seen this coming
well we've known for a long time that
there are substantive vacancy
rates within london and that coupled
with the now high vacancy rate due to
nurses having to go off sick or having
to isolate i think is is the perfect
storm especially as we're seeing
nurses uh having to cope with more and
more patients because we're not only
dealing with covered patients but that
huge backlog of waiting lists as well
well you say more and more patience but
this time last year the number of people
in hospital was less and even though
we know that january's under strain the
health service coped so why so bad this
time
well
last time we were able to wind down some
services so we weren't doing as many
elected theater cases but this time
we're still dealing with those patients
we're not winding down any services at
the moment we've got many more nurses
off sick we've also still got the
vacancy debates um so and we've still
got 4 000 copic patients in hospital so
we are still dealing with significant
pressures and we've been working now
under those pressures for two years so
we also have a workforce that's
extremely tired and burnt out
and how does this translate currently
into care for patients then well it
means that the nurses are very stretched
um
as a nurse myself i can tell you that we
go into work and we want to be able to
find the best possible care for our
patients so i can tell you that we've
got nurses at the moment that aren't
taking their breaks that are working
late that are coming in on their days
off that i can't slip their leave
but that's not sustainable and we can't
continue with running on the goodwill of
nurses who need to come up with
long-term solutions and not just
short-term fixes
lisa elliott from the royal college of
nursing thank you for your time today